most companies don't have the patience
for their people to grow I don't have
patience to wait and help you on your
growth journey I need my growth and I
you did my my numbers it reminds me Gary
Ridge who used to be the CEO of WD40 he
was on an analyst call and the analyst
said Gary you missed your numbers and he
goes no my numbers are fine I missed
your numbers but to Gary's credit he has
a company that invests in like if you're
in a leadership track they they teach
you how to be a coach they teach you
coaching they understand that people's
performances don't always match the
arbitrary numbers of the arbitrary dates
of running our companies he has the
institutional patience to allow someone
to go in a growth Journey with their ups
and downs even if it means that he has
to suffer short term because he
recognizes that over the long term he
will benefit which by the way they have
it's a very very high performing
organization this is why I like
quarterly or at least semiannual reviews
at least then I can see
growth